In the world of professional gambling, there
is a well documented hot streak of near-mythical
status referred to by many as “The Run”.
During this streak, a man known as Archie
Karas turned $50 into $40 million by primarily
shooting pool and playing poker in Vegas.
What makes this run so infamous is that, after
winning more money than most people could
spend in a lifetime, Karas lost it all in
the span of a few weeks.
The Run began in 1992 when Karas (aka: Anargyros
Karabourniotis) drove to Las Vegas with approximately
$50 in his pocket.
The then 41 year old had originally come to
America from Greece via working aboard a cruise
ship as a waiter.
Before that, he ran away from home at the
age of 15 after his father attacked him with
a shovel.
Once in America, he developed prodigious skill
at both pool and poker, and several times
made himself a millionaire via gambling in
California, only to lose much of it shortly
thereafter.
Notably, directly before his famous trip to
Vegas, he managed to accumulate over $2 million
before losing most all of it playing poker.
Rather than quit, he decided to head to Vegas
to try his luck there.
archie-karasKaras’ previous experience playing
high-stakes poker helped him turn his $50
into $10,000 almost immediately when he bumped
into a high-roller at The Mirage he’d previously
played with and convinced him to give him
$10,000.
The high-roller, knowing Karas’ skill, happily
lent him the money and watched as he turned
it into $30,000 in a matter of hours at the
poker tables.
In repayment of the loan, Karas gave the man
$20,000 and headed for the pool halls with
the remaining $10,000.
There Karas, who’d spent years hustling
people at pool while working next door to
a pool hall in LA, ran into a fellow pool
shark he has only ever referred to as “Mr.
X” in interviews “out of respect for him
and his position.”
To quote Karas on he and Mr. X’s first encounter
in Vegas: “We knew each other from the past,
and it took no time at all to agree to play
a game of 9-ball.
We started shooting 9-ball for something pretty
small, like $5,000 per game.”
Over the course of about two and half months,
Karas and this mystery man met many dozens
of times to play pool for ever increasing
sums of money, eventually culminating in both
men agreeing to play for a whopping $40,000
per game, which inevitably resulted in hundreds
of thousands of dollars changing hands every
night.
In one particularly heated set, according
to Karas, he lost $320,000 dollars in “about
40 seconds” when Mr. X was able to sink
the 9 ball on his break an astounding eight
times out of ten, something Karas had never
even heard of happening before.
He stated of this,
I don’t rattle easy, but that rattled me,
as I didn’t even get the chance to shoot
one ball in those games.
It is hard to fade, believe me.
It felt like I was throwing $40,000 at a time,
right out of a car window in seconds, over
and over again, and my hard-earned money was
flying off into the wind.
That said, Karas was still way ahead, having
netted around $1.2 million from Mr. X at this
point.
Nonetheless, he decided Mr. X was simply too
good to beat consistently over a large sample
set.
Knowing his opponent wouldn’t want to let
him walk away with over a million dollars
of his money, Karas offered to change the
game, telling Mr. X, “If you want to gamble
with me, let’s go play some poker.”
Like their pool games, the stakes between
both men quickly became high at upwards of
$15,000 per hand while playing seven card
stud- an amount Karas describes as “unheard
of in those days”.
After three weeks of playing poker with Mr.
X and others, Karas had another $3 million
in his pocket from those games and the same
playing dice in between poker matches, bringing
his total up to $7 million in about three
months of gambling.
Rather than retiring an living off the interest,
Karas set up shop at Binion’s Gambling Hall
and Hotel (then known as Binion’s Horseshoe)
and simply sat at the highest stakes poker
table with $5 million in chips in front of
him.
To psyche out any potential opponents, Karas
would occasionally stand up and go to the
bar or toilet, leaving the $5 million on the
table like he didn’t even care about it.
In reality, the money was being closely watched
over by casino security, but it did cause
enough of a stir to pique the interest of
some of the biggest poker stars of the day.
Over the next six months, Karas won an additional
$10 million from some of the best card players
of all time including Stu Ungar (widely considered
the best Texas Hold ‘Em player ever), Chip
Reese (one of the youngest players ever inducted
into the poker hall of fame) and Johnny Chan
(one of only a handful of people in history
to have won the World Series of Poker main
event consecutively).
During this particular hot streak, Karas continually
tried to raise the stakes against his opponents
until he was playing half-million dollar games.
While this earned him an undeniable amount
of kudos from his peers, it had the adverse
effect of ultimately scaring away nearly every
high-roller in Vegas.
And so it was that after six months of dominating
high-stakes poker, losing only one major game
to Johnny Chan, Karas got bored of chasing
opponents and decided to take his $17 million
to the dice tables at the Binion Horseshoe,
as they prided themselves on allowing customers
to bet more money at once than any other casino
in Vegas.
In the end, Karas was able to convince the
casino to allow him to bet $100,000 per dice
roll, 20 times more than any other casino
in the area offered and 5 times what other
customers at Binion’s could bet.
Briefly, Karas even topped that after convincing
the owner to allow him to bet $200,000 on
a single roll- a concession that was quickly
rescinded when Karas won nearly a million
dollars in two consecutive rolls.
On another occasion, Karas won almost every
$5000 chip (the largest at that establishment
at the time) the casino had and ultimately
walked out carrying $3 million in cash that
day which he nonchalantly dumped onto his
car’s passenger seat before driving to the
bank.
(He did later note that he carried a gun with
him when walking around with large sums.)
At the end of this final streak, Karas had
managed to acquire another $13 million, bringing
his total winnings over this two and a half
year period to over $40 million (about $65
million today).
It’s at this point that his unprecedented
run stopped cold.
Over the course of the next few weeks, Karas
lost about $17 million playing baccarat, $11
million playing dice and $2 million playing
poker against Johnny Chan.
Just like that, 75% of his fortune was gone.
These losses shook the normally ice cold Karas
enough to prompt him to return to his native
Greece for a few weeks to catch his breath.
But the allure of Vegas and the highs of gambling
tempted him back and he proceeded to lose
another $10 million or so almost immediately
upon return, leaving him with about $1 million
to his name.
Karas briefly regained his luck, winning about
$2 million in a single high-stake poker match
against Chan, but lost all these winnings
playing dice directly after.
After this final losing streak, Karas was
broke; he’d lost just over $40 million in
about a month’s worth of gambling.
By his own estimation, during The Run, Karas
gambled over a billion dollars.
Whether true or not, the better documented
exploits during his streak would seem to indicate
he’s probably not far off when he states
he’s gambled more money than any single
human being in history, except for “people
on Wall Street”.
As for why he continued when he could have
easily just walked away one of the richest
people in the world, Karas stated: “Money
means nothing to me.
I don’t value it.
I’ve had all the material things I could
ever want.
Everything.
The things I want, money can’t buy: health,
freedom, love, happiness.
I don’t care about money, so I have no fear.
I don’t care if I lose it.”
Showing that lack of fear, after losing that
$40 million, Karas continued gambling, managing
to win and lose millions of dollars a few
times over in the two decades since.
Notable in these mini-runs was the time in
1996 when he turned $40,000 into about $5
million, then promptly lost it all the day
after winning approximately 80% of that sum.
Unfortunately for Karas, he won’t be able
to go on any other such runs in Vegas for
the foreseeable future.
Why?
In 2015, he was added to Nevada’s infamous
“Black Book” (a list of people banned
from ever gambling in the state) after being
found guilty of marking cards in a blackjack
game in 2013.
In the end, Karas summed up his view on his
gambling career, “I consider myself the
king of gamblers.
I made it, I lost it and like Frank Sinatra
says, I stood tall and I took the punches
and I did it my way.”